welcome back to new rock stars loki
episode 4 set up with our heads and as
it blew our minds with new timekeeper
revelations
and a whole fresh crop of loki variants
protect alligator loki at all costs by
the way because
i don't know what that is but it seems
really cool this is rogue theory the
show where we pitch the wildest theories
for the nerdy titles that we love
my name is mt and with me going rogue
today is of course the amazing
jessica clemens hi and if anyone harms
my little alligator loki i will lose my
as you should because amphibians have
rights too and of course everyone's
favorite variant
tommy bech told what's going on big head
good hey big head gang
peaches and cream i just got these
sick alligator boots that i made uh it's
weird though one of them has a little
gold set of horns on it
[Laughter]
wow you hunted that yourself huh
interesting
and returning guests and fellow super
nerd tom michelson hello tom nice to
meet you
i'm so glad to be back i am to keep the
alligator uh
metaphors going i'm the alligator loki
to the tommy original
loki so i'm the uh the other tom but i
i'm not
i want to see more animal loki's
honestly because why not you've
you've already opened the the gates i
honestly hope that loki comes from the
spider
spider ham you know
[Laughter]
with this new episode of loki we of
course got introduced to all these
interesting variants like bose for loki
and we have gator loki and of course
classic loki played by
richard e grant in the background of
where all this is happening appears to
be the ruins of new york well today's
first rogue question is
how did all these loki's get there how
can they escape
and where do people go when they get
pruned and what other loki variants
might we see it would just be so amazing
to get to see
get to see all the now that the universe
is wide open we can see
any of them so like do you have like an
idea of how they could have gotten there
in the first place so
it will definitely have something to do
with the uh with that stick that the
pruning stick
i think that they were getting to this
planet so first off i
after watching this i was like i am so
eager to see what episode 5 is going to
look like
so if you re-watch the trailer you'll
see that there's a part where loki
stands up in this wide field that's
empty
and it's the same scene that we see at
the very end and the
mid credits uh so it's the same scene
but you can't see the three people that
are in it
and you can tell that that's the
avengers tower in the background so this
is something that is a destroyed planet
either through
the tva uh when they reset things they
maybe send people to this
because i like the idea of the ti the
prison the prison time that they kept
putting loki into with sif
and so maybe this is a timeline that is
just a prison planet
where they're putting all the loki's or
whether they put all the people they
reset
because and i also think that we're
going to see president loki in this
timeline
so i think all the people that are reset
and put there are also there along with
the loki's that are there
so i think they're pruned and put onto
this part of a timeline
where they can't get out of obviously
because they're all there
but i think that's how they got there in
the first place so do you think that c20
is there as well
yes i think so because i really do want
to see that president loki scene that we
see in the trailer
in that same time in the same space
because it would make sense why he's
just
and then we'd get this fun battle of all
the loki's of him being like why does
anybody listen to me i'm the president
loki
even though this could be a world where
that president loki just blew it up
and so they're in this part of new york
and that's where they're vanished to at
all times
but i think we're gonna see all the
people that are reset also put they're
pruned
put there just because it's like when
they all in the trailer when they all
put their swords and their
daggers up to his throat who were all
these people and i think there's all the
variants that were or the people that
were just pruned in general
that are like following this loki but
this loki is just like
a piece of crap so i think how they're
going to get off
i can't say maybe sylvia's going to get
a temp pad and get them out of it
but i think every one of these loki's
have been put in the same timeline
and they've just been in hiding because
maybe it's just like a
mad max world where they're um
they're just like when they were like
yeah you're gonna be in hell if you
don't hurry up and follow us it's
because all these other variants are
just they're
destroying each other it's like a
battlefield i like that it's just like a
whole world full of variants or
discarded variants sort of
and it also makes sense for like how
sloppy they're now being if you can tell
they're getting kind of let's get into a
point where you're like oh okay so the
time variance authority isn't really a
thing it's like so
one it's one person somehow that's very
smart and able to control
all of these humans and so it's like hey
you guys are just getting loose now with
it it's all falling apart all right i
like that
oh yeah i like the uh i like the idea of
it being uh
worlds that they go to but i think of it
more as
the tva being dishonest about what
pruning is in the first place most
people that see pruning assume it's
death it's a death sentence
i think even from the beginning
whoever's in charge of the tva never
intended
the prune sticks to in the in the act of
pruning to be a death sentence i think
it's more of a transported teleportation
device to
individualized prison cells i think
where loki is right now
is the prison where all loki variants
and all consequences
of loki variance actions go almost like
a massive
raiders of the lost ark storage unit at
the end where it just goes
so we see the avengers tower in the
background and it looks destroyed like a
apocalyptic manhattan maybe that is a
timeline
where there was a variant loki that
succeeded with the chitauri in
destroying manhattan and flattening and
defeating the avengers
then corrected by the tva so in my
opinion
these are all i don't i don't think
mobius is there i don't think c20 is
there i think they're in their own
separate uh like kind of like prison
storage units
with other variants i mean in a way it
kind of undercuts the maliciousness
of someone in the tva but i wonder
we still don't quite know what uh the
remaining
living tva employees intentions are
which is i think we'll find out when
sylvie
does her big inquisition next week so
my thought is just that everyone has
been
kind of like very similar to how loki
always operates people just assume
things of him and then the reality is
revealed other people are just assuming
pruning means death
when in reality it might just mean
you're taking
to another you're stored almost like
data in a matrix like prison
that would be insane to see a data yeah
exactly
like in a hawaiian shirt tan having just
jet skied for weeks
oh i can play like marvel if you need it
it's funny tommy i think you know that i
think you could be right too about a
prison planet and not being a proper
timeline because one thing i was
wondering is
you know when you got two loki's
together on lamentis
it and they had a connection it
immediately created this
sharp spike in the timeline right they'd
have to be in a place
that wouldn't necessarily be affected
like that like a prison otherwise
you know if anybody started uh feeling
another loki because you know loki's
being loki's he just started feeling
each other they might end up being like
that
dragon world that and rick and morty
where they you know
they soul bond all day long right right
right
huge orgy on disney plus
the entire time i kept trying to figure
out why
like because she was even trying to
inquire about what her nexus event was
and that's and so it's like i don't i
want to believe
that because it's i want to believe your
theory right there
tom but then i'm also just like then why
put all these loki's in the same planet
i think the the real reality of it is
yeah these ones are problems but the
real problem with sylvie
she also talks about at the very
beginning so i really
held on to the fact at the very
beginning she when she was playing with
her dolls
she was like the valkyrie come swoop in
and i was like oh this is and then she's
the hero we have the hero song playing i
was like she's a really good person
she's different from all the loki's and
i don't think i think it was either a
the fact that she was just a really
sweet female loki that the variants were
like
we can't have her in this world because
loki's are chaos they're supposed to be
the gods of chaos here we have a goddess
that's just the sweetest little girl
uh we can't have her exist in this
timeline so i think she was the event
more so than like
them falling in love though i'm not one
of those people online
they can't be in love i was confused
because i thought they were it was like
are they siblings kind of i guess not
i was a little confused but now i'm not
now i'm all i'm
they're not well technically i'm for it
at first i was just like it was more so
like
like i was just like yourself honestly
don't knock it till you try it
sweet home alabama
[Laughter]
very expensive
that reminded me of another idea i had
is because you know about her being a
good person
and being a good loki and not taking her
out and when she was playing with the
valkyries and seeming like a good kid i
was like what if in her
in her timeline she was actually good
and would become a valkyrie
and having a good rookie that allowed
becoming a valkyrie and becomes a hero
of asgard would be the reason why they
would nip her
from the timeline right but uh her being
a veteran because her first action
was hela with the black head and she had
the little uh feminist
doll wolf i was like wait is it they're
trying to say she's held or something
but then they
they went away but yeah i'm wondering if
that was maybe what it was but the fact
that it was
so unmemorable for her i would have
loved her to be a valkyrie
but i also just say i just think she's a
good person she was a child
that's the hard part is that she was a
child so really her
what her goals in life are limitless but
it was just that she was a good child
that she was obviously destined to just
be like a sweet person and not
try to loki's can't be heroes that was
like their whole tvas thing was like
they can't be a hero
if you die you have to you can't die a
hero because you're not a hero
so to have her exist in the world is
just already chaos
they were like we gotta take her out um
or she was
detrimental to kang's plan these are all
fantastic theories you guys are super
super smart
but i think now that i have to reward uh
rogue bucks
which is a currency i'm just gonna
completely just
be wild with i'm going to award 3 000
points to mr tom michaelson
three interesting
so you guys all already have the most
points if any rogue
ever so please uh pat yourselves on the
back for
a momentous occasion anyways before we
continue with all that over at
newrockstarsmerch.com we've unveiled the
first
shirt design with our limited edition
latest obsession series
loki out of time buying the latest
obsession shirt will give you the
ability to leave a message
on our inside marvel loki after show
with either a shout out or
your own rogue theory and it'll show up
during the show and we got a full line
of loki inspired merch
including an augmented reality shirt
miss minute stickers tva buttons and
other cool stuff that hasn't even been
released yet so find it all over
at newrockstarsmerch.com but of course
we also have to thank
our homies down at helix sleep for
sponsoring this whole show
now whether a day job is being a master
of the mystic arts a billionaire playboy
philanthropist or
an accountant at the end of the day you
want to sleep in a bed designed for your
specific needs helix sleep has a quiz
that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you they have soft medium
and firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
side sleepers
here at new rockstars eric took the quiz
and got matched with the dusk
luxe helix mattress a medium firm beauty
with lumbar support that sleeps cool
and he's been slubbering like a boss
ever since he got it so you know the
mattress ships right to your door for
free and you never need to go to a
mattress store
ever again don't do it it's weird what
if there's bed bugs there who knows
i'm not saying every mattress store has
bed bugs but you don't want to take the
chance
and they were awarded the number one
best overall mattress of 2020 by gq in
wired magazine and helix is offering up
to 200
off all mattresses orders and two free
pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
rogue theory that is healysleep.com
rogue theory for up to 200 off and two
free pillows
and rogue theory is also sponsored by
credit karma money credit karma has
always been there to help you
make better financial decisions and now
they want to help even more with a
credit karma money spend account you can
be rewarded for good money habits credit
karma money is a brand new checking
account where you can win
cash reimbursements for making purchases
and when you use your credit karma money
debit card you can win
daily instant karma purchase
reimbursements on items up to
five thousand dollars just pay with your
debit card and if you win you'll be
notified on the spot and your instant
karma cash will be added back to your
spend account
open your fdi insured spend account for
free and there's no minimum balance
requirements and free withdrawals from
over 50 000 atms
and when you make a purchase between
july 1st and july 23rd you'll
automatically be entered to win
1 million so go to creditkarma.com
win money to sign up for free and start
winning instant karma that's
creditkarma.com win money insta karma is
sponsored by credit karma
no purchase necessary exclusions and
terms apply see the rules banking
services provided by
mvv bank incorporated member fdic
maximum balance and transfer limits
apply and rogue theory is also brought
to you by bespoke post
as your undertaking summer adventures
take bespoke post with you their new
lineup of essential box of awesome
collections for guys are guaranteed to
upgrade your life no matter what you're
into some of my favorite boxes from the
past have great shirts i wear
all the time cool kitchen equipment and
some fun travel gear so whether you're
out taming the wilderness or taking your
home bar to
pro level heights bespoke post only
sends guys the best stuff
every month and box of awesomeness
collections for every part of your life
their new parked box comes with a cool
camp chair and the hecho box comes with
everything you need to level up your
taco night to get started take the quiz
at box of awesome.com and your answers
will help them pick up the right box of
awesome for you
and they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel anytime and each box
costs only 45 bucks but has over 70
dollars
worth of gear on the inside so get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com and enter the
code
rogue at checkout that's box of
awesome.com
code rogue for 20 off your first
box okay guys continuing on with the
episode so this episode had a very
interesting quote from mobius that stuck
out to all of us i feel
when he mentioned vampires being brought
in by the tva in the past
now is this setting up a blade's
introduction to the mcu
and how could blade first appear in the
mcu
i don't know if this is an introduction
to blade more so it's just like a name
drop
you know what i'm saying i think it's
just a it's a little taste
it's a little taste it's oh it's a
little peppery it's just a little bit
um elantra i i think it's just like they
said it just like how they said and um
falcon winter soldier the like wizards
whatever this it's just like so you know
that like oh it's in the universe
but on the side of that so i'm not a
realist or i'm not a dreamer i guess in
that case where i'm just like i think he
just said it doesn't say it like just to
acknowledge that yes vampires do
are in this world which is great to have
acknowledged because then it's like okay
how can we bring in blade and i think a
way uh the greatest way
i want to bring in blade is just through
the midnight suns that way we can have a
connection
um with ghost writer and bring them in
here uh i really like ghost rider just
as much as erika wusu loves ghost rider
so i i just think it'd be fun to bring
him in all guns blazing
but um i also think that blade was such
and i know that like blade walks so the
rest of these movies could run
but it also is such a good standalone
movie on its own
that i do want him kind of how we got uh
jessica jones and how we got luke cage
i kind of want it in on its own i want
it on its own
bring it into the bring it into the mcu
for sure like i'd still be happy with
that
but blade is such a good stand alone
that i kind of just want him to be on
his own does that make sense
i don't want to i don't want to
segregate him
that maybe wasn't the right word it was
something it was like several games
the way you looked at
out of the upcoming mcu projects which
do you think blade is
most likely to cameo in this one if i
didn't see the
only because it's like we're opening
well if he
okay so uh from what we hear right now
um i think the more
the more realistic way he would drop is
a different timeline you know
so i think this would be the right way
to introduce him don't think he's gonna
show up but this
would be a good one or doctor strange
from the trailers we've seen there seems
to be so much underworld fighting going
on in that trailer
people in dark bars with people fighting
it makes a lot of sense
yo i would myself if blade showed
up
i would literally wow that doesn't make
a lot of sense i like that because i was
even thinking like you know he would
have to show up in one of the more
grounded
i mean not i don't want to be grounded
but you know in one of the street levels
oh yeah
properties and i was actually thinking
he might be in moonlight
i mean even watching the behind the
scenes uh of like oscar isaac doing that
fighting in the choreography
yeah i can imagine which were like moon
gods in the night i can imagine
introducing or talking about blade a
little bit more in that but you know and
getting back to the first question if he
was going to be in this like i could
easily see them
making him a tv agent you know like he's
a hunter already he's a vampire hunter
so i could see that
i kind of don't want to because that
would be really easy
um and so i could see that but i also
i'm wondering if this is more of a
business decision
to talk to name drop vampires because
you know we're now getting to a point
where marvel and the mcu cannot
stop the sony universe of movies like it
or not
you know would have more bs on deck
after you know venom two
and and and you know kevin feige isn't
necessarily i think involved in those in
the
and and not to dig on them you know the
quality control of making sure they fit
inside canon and universe and all of
that
so by name dropping the multiverse and
that multiple places exist by name
dropping vampires
you're you're priming the audience to
accept that the other versions of this
exists and that therefore if it's not
that good don't worry because we got all
these other multiverse multiverses over
here and we're doing this
and i think that's another reason why
they're they're they're opening up
the multiverse with spider-man you know
because we can't stop tony wanting to
just start
you know using all these characters so i
wonder if that was if it's really more
of a behind-the-scenes
business decision blade i can see doing
this marshalla
no um and by doing this i mean so like
as in like
reading blade in the comics it's like
okay yeah maybe he would do something
like this
but it's like imagining like because
wesley snipes when playing blade was
like i don't take
anything from nobody and that's how i
see marshalla too so i feel like it's
gonna be hard
to get him to work with other people not
like actual martial the character
to like theoretically like play around
with other people even though in the
comics he does
but like can you imagine martial working
on a team no
he works alone and so uh i'm very
excited for blade
i think the uh the vampire thing like
all like most marvel
things it's a great little appetizer it
probably won't pay off in loki
i think shangshi and the uh legend of
the ten rings is where we're gonna get
our first blade that's what i said
if the dark hold sorry if the darkhold
comes in more so
i guess he can come in with a darkhold
um are we gonna
see are we where was the other
opportunity that we're gonna see that
other than doctor strange
right we went so no i i hold my guns and
say doctor stranger loki sounds good
well these are all fantastic answers but
i'm going to give
a good 2 000 points to my boy tommy b
because that answer i really i really
like the whole shanxi element because
like it's true
like we could see uh like him pop up in
that blood sport fight
and i would literally pee my pants i
would literally my mind would
would explode because i'm like oh my god
we're getting it already so
i'm gonna give 2 000 points to mr tommy
b 1 000 points
to jess and tom for their excellent
answers
because you guys empty people do you
hate me
i'm sorry i don't hate you i promise i
don't hate you i just i'm just giving
out points wildly
okay well excellent answers like you
guys are so smart i
love listening to you guys but we are on
to our rogue
question of the day which is okay
the temple of doom indiana jones fedora
sold for
350 000 at an auction this week
350 more thousand dollars than a fedora
is worth
in my opinion but whatever but
what movie prop would you pay more money
than you have for
and why i think i would um
i would pay at auction a decent amount
for all of the leftover real cocaine
al pacino did in scarface
you know they collected that i
would buy i would honest to god i would
buy
a uh r2d2 oh
yeah that's so good yeah that would be a
baller thing to show off to your friends
when they come over like oh it's just
the real rgd no big deal you know
the actual i think the basketball from
space jam
the original space scam from house would
be something worth so
much money because it's just even though
it's like cgi it's still like this
is the prop that we use for michael
jordan
in this remarkable movie he goes
and he stretches that's the noise i
think he made um i i don't know if i
would pay
i love space jam don't know if i would
pay that much for that problem
my world would be like something from
like something stupid
like fast and the furious i don't know
but my thing from is fast and fear so i
was gonna say like
one of those cars that can flip and
avoid missiles that you know that's very
very practical that would go very well
and help you in traffic
you know you have so many but actually i
think real a real fan thing i would
really want is um
the 1989 batmobile the michael keaton
batmobile but if it worked if
that would be pretty sick you know a24
was selling doing an
auction of their products from movies
which a24
great place to be selling products and
they were selling stuff like
from the lighthouse the like mermaid
like stick
and they went it sold for like a mill i
swear to god it sold for so much
they were a24 is such a successful like
production company
that let alone like selling props from
midsummer or just like
hereditary people are gonna beat that
stuff up to answer this question myself
because i
think that's the reason i so you know
you guys obviously know i i love gardens
in the galaxy that's a very big film for
me
and so in in the broker's um
little shop in guards and galaxy one
there's this cube inside of it that
looks so beautiful
and like i've wanted that cube for the
longest time
it's like a rainbow cube it's so it's so
nice but it's so
like this it was made by this glass
maker that like he's super super diesel
at making glasses forget his name
but like those things like run for like
thousands of dollars like so to actually
get that prop
is a very costly disney like hanging in
the guardians ride that would be sick
that would be
amazing but i highly doubt it please if
anyone is at disneyland and they find it
just steal it for me i'll give you
twenty dollars for your efforts
okay so to wrap this question up i'm
gonna give
i'm gonna give two thousand points to
miss jess clemens because space jam
is amazing hands behind my back hands
tied behind my back i'm gonna do it now
a thousand points to the boys
because those are also great ideas i do
like batmobile
dig it but no i think that makes
tom our winner if i'm not mistaken
thank you i'll i'll take i'll take a w
one time
these are the rock stars over here so
i'll accept it this one time thank you
thank you
of course but that is it for our episode
of world theory thank you to our guests
jessica clemens tom michelson and tommy
beck told
us for joining us today support our
channel by checking out our new loki
theme merch at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at mastertainment if you like
weird and follow new rockstars
wherever we are on twitter on youtube
but when we if you do follow us on
youtube make sure to hit that
notification bell to get notifications
whenever we upload a video
thank you guys for watching and we will
see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you